your next performer i hope i'm saying
the name right hands kim
thank you it's precisely correct um
i promise amy hans kid um
i think it's fine that tanner is a white
person's name
tanner than what you white [ __ ]
should be like hey this is my mexican
friend tanner
that's my black fantastic
i love being asian i a lot of people
make fun of us because we dogs which i
understand can be very shocking because
in america dogs are treated like family
members
but in asia we treat our family members
like family members
this real tradition we have back home
where instead of buying an animal we
just love our grandma
should everyone better in asia unless
they're a baby girl which gets you
thrown in the river
um the dog in the river uh it's chaotic
i uh i think it's funny that uh there's
a lot of
racism because i'm not racist i'm a
minority how could i be impossible
i don't even see race i only smell it
it's a little polish in here
i was on an airplane and i saw dude
reading a book in arabic which really
freaked me out
but then i saw him in the corner of the
page and put the book away and i was
like oh thank god he's got future plans
for the power literature um i am uh
having a hard time getting booked in
comedy i think it's because the people
who book shows only book their friends
and my friends book based on merit
how do i get some of these shitty
friends i just want to be rewarded for
the way i happen to be
born i don't want to work hard anyone
can make it by
working hard that's cheating you better
be rewarded for your primordial
personality that's the american way
um yeah i uh i'm worried that people
don't like me in the comedy scene
because as we all know the best comedy
comes from people that are really nice
that everyone really likes
so that's kind of a worry for me
i love uh doing real shows open mics
aren't even real comedy okay real comedy
is about pandering to tourists
well we're saying one liners right here
we could be asking tourists where
they're from
i love open mics it's like we're playing
house with comedy
it's my turn to be the comedian
he's been a comedian too long
we're all children man what are we even
doing we could be having a job right now
uh i am uh unemployed i uh
i'm jealous of you employed people i
wish i could send pointless emails and
copy and pasting sells
spreadsheets uh from one place to the
next one i reason
uh i saw a truck uh it said uh
you can hire me for 20 bucks an hour and
i was like damn that truck makes twice
what i make
i could be doubling my salary right now
if i was a truck
i mean i think capitalism is fine if you
want to do it just don't make everyone
play a stupid game
i like fortnite i don't make your
grandma playing take away her house if
she loses
yeah i think communism is fine i like
how americans will be like how music
never works and if we didn't spend
billions of dollars and kill millions of
people to make sure it wouldn't work
do i have time am i done okay
so here's how the joke ends uh you know
they're like remember the war in vietnam
and panama
and uh cuba we're pretty anxious about
communism not working
americans are like cognizant never works
because whenever people control the
means of production they're
democratically elected leaders they
seriously die
and this the small rebel group always
finds automatic weapons
and look they're hitting themselves why
are you destabilizing yourself are you
just stabilizing yourself thank you